It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's Friday, and it's also our 160th episode today!
Thank you for your support!
That's a lot of mornings, Moco-chan.
Thank you, Ruffians, for waking up for 160 mornings together with us!
BAU BAU!
Well, for the Ruffians, maybe this is your first morning with us!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short, warm-up morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off
On the right paw.
So to do that, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, did you remember your BAU BAU?
Yeah!
Are you awake?
Today is a morning, a Friday morning.
Are we gonna start it off on the right paw?
Okay, Ruffians.
Close enough.
You might be awake, but who knows?
I think you're awake.
It's just a guess.
Definitely, yeah.
BAU BAU!
You're still a little sleepy.
In that case... BAU BAU!
In that case...
I have some news for you.
News?
Ruffians!
News Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO Mornings don't end easy.
No.
That's good news then.
No bad news.
It's not as bad as I'm thinking though.
Let's take a look.
Okay, where is Pero Sighting now?
De-den!
Hi.
I don't like eating acrylic.
I feel like if he wanted to, he could.
He could definitely.
He could.
It's an option for him.
It's probably not the most delicious, but... Hopefully he didn't because, you know, those are precious, precious treasures.
But I guess, yeah, this would probably be a pretty good home for him.
He kind of does blend in to some degree, but he's not acrylic!
No!
He's not acrylic!
He's caramel!
I didn't say it, that's what the Ruffians were saying!
I don't know if that's factual.
Not that big.
I didn't say it, the Ruffians did.
But, but, but, I could say it, the Ruffians!
The precious treasures!
Pero, we need to get Pero out of there!
If we don't see them, they must be in his tummy, huh?
Well, uh, I'm gonna hold this somewhere, and not just the tummy.
If they're in the tummy, then you're gonna have to take things into your own paws, Ruffians!
But you know, I think one thing, if we look at this picture very well, I think this Ruffian's gonna be needing some more room for new treasures that maybe come along the way soon.
Yeah.
Right, maybe this Ruffian also has to learn how to be a surgeon.
You had to make room and obviously you don't have room for nasty demon dogs.
That's all.
Be safe about it, you might bite back.
You have to be careful.
BAU BAU!
Be careful always, okay?
You have to keep your eyes open.
BAU BAU!
Happy news!
Today!
Today, fresh news!
It's Nobuko-senpai's birthday!
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday!
FUWAMOCO-senpai!
It's her birthday!
She just finished having her 3D birthday live!
Actually, I heard that this is her first birthday live in two years!
Seems hard to believe!
I don't believe it.
Right!
Two years?
Amazing!
Really?
Yeah!
But I'm so glad, I'm so glad we got another Roboco-senpai 3D birthday!
And an amazing set that's filled with really cool songs like Odor!
But!
But?
But
Even better!
It's really cute.
I love the odango, the big odango.
The buttons, they're so cute.
Kind of like ears, you know.
Big ears.
Yeah, like big ears.
Very stylish.
I feel like Roboco-senpai is always very stylish.
Very stylish, yeah.
We have the really cool umbrella too, you know.
Rest down or dress up with the umbrella and then the jacket with a bit of plush bed too.
So cool, very very stylish.
Just thinking, I wonder which hololive member has the most amount of glasses for FUWAMOCO.
I feel like Roboco-senpai has a lot of glasses now.
That's true, but I don't think she's the number one.
I'm curious who's the number one glasses owner.
It's a good question, yes!
But you know, Dobuko-senpai... I just, I love Dobuko-senpai's singing voice.
It's so unique.
So I feel so lucky that we got another CD live.
And I hope we get more originals too.
I love Dobuko-senpai's originals, but...
On the topic of new music too, Roboco-senpai also just released a brand new song cover of Oni no Utage, Demon's Banquet.
So please check it out!
Extra extra cool Roboco-senpai straight to you, Carol fans!
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday Roboco-senpai!
Bye!
There's so many happy things, exciting things going on and Nerissa's gonna be having her first 3D content very soon too!
Lots of stuff!
Lots and lots of stuff!
It's FUWAMOCO News!
We're happy to say that we finished all our sightings!
All the sightings for our birthday!
Ruffians!
Maybe our birthday merch is getting just that much closer to reaching you!
Yeah!
And you know this time, Mayuri-chan, she was praising us and we've gotten so much faster!
Right!
You know, it was to the point where we were like, do we make a mistake?
Is this enough?
Right!
So we double checked and we triple checked to make sure that we didn't forget a bunch of them or something.
But no!
Yeah!
We did it!
Are there any extra special ones?
I always wonder about that.
Sometimes I'm like, oh maybe this one didn't turn out right.
But then I look at it and no, it looks the same.
I always wonder though, you know, what happens to the extras?
Who knows?
I only messed up a couple times this time.
10 times.
Is there any SSL sneeze cards?
I don't think so.
Not this time.
But very very careful.
Yes!
Although, my hands were feeling a bit dry at one point, so I put on some hand cream.
Yeah, and then I thought, oh, let's just put on hand cream.
You know that one, right?
What if we get the oil and the cream out?
Right!
That's what I was worried about.
Oh no!
The cards don't smell really good!
Maybe you could smell the cards to see.
Does it smell like FUWAMOCO?
Scratch and sniff cards!
Don't scratch them!
Okay.
But you know, we always have a bunch of fun stuff.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
That makes us so happy.
And we just listen to really cool music too.
I don't know, we kind of go into like a happy trance while doing it, right?
Yeah, at one point though, I fell asleep.
Not while signing, in the middle of signature.
No, I just paused.
I just leaned back into a quick ten minute nap and then I was like, okay!
Back to it.
But you know, it really is special.
So we're really excited to have them.
Reach your paws open!
And hand pain status.
Good.
I think good.
Right, Moco-chan?
I would say 0%.
0%.
I had a cat mark in my paw.
But otherwise I'm good.
Yeah.
Pretty good.
And on that note, that's good because we just found out that we'll be getting...
Ruffians!
If you get this up right now, you can still get the special foil stamp signature cards!
I like it better too, Abyss.
I like the foil stamp on better, so please don't feel like I can get delimited!
Yeah, I know.
I just like it better.
You can still get your paws on it right now, Ruffians!
Pre-orders end at the end of this month, a little bit at the beginning of next month.
So soon, right?
So please check them out for good!
BAU BAU!
I'm not looking forward to sighting more, it's too hot.
It's just nice.
It's relaxing.
Yeah.
Moco-chan's the fastest at signing doors.
But that makes sense.
We have a new group of plushies!
That was just announced!
A series of plushies are coming out with the plushie maker Make Shoe!
Ugh, makeshift's a little bit different.
Right!
For these plushies to become reality, you need to find them!
Yes!
I want to put my voice towards this!
I want this!
But!
It already happened!
You did it, Ruffian!
It'll be coming to reality!
Thank you so much for all your support!
For supporting all of it!
And you know this time, look!
We're all kind of really cute beans!
Bean shapes!
FUWAMOCO On top of a fan mascot!
FUWAMOCO Look at the pebble there.
Pebble's kinda big compared to the jailbird.
FUWAMOCO Right.
FUWAMOCO Right, the big pebble.
FUWAMOCO I feel like the pebble could eat the jailbird.
FUWAMOCO Hi.
FUWAMOCO Is that what we're gonna do, Moco-chan?
FUWAMOCO I could take that jailbird!
BAU BAU!
But you know, we saw a number of Ruffians kind of, huh?
Wait, huh?
Fuwa's on top of the pink Ruffian, Moco-chan's on top of the blue Ruffian.
What?
What is this about?
The pairing doesn't make sense to me.
Did they make a mistake?
No Ruffians!
I know I mentioned it a little bit before.
But maybe there's some Ruffians that forgot.
But that's because they're both Ruffians!
The blue Ruffian is not Fuwawa, I'm blue.
But the blue Ruffian is my Ruffian, the pink Ruffian.
No, Moco-chan's Ruffian.
Ruffian's a Ruffian, you know.
You know, this was a request that we made.
We wanted it this way, yes!
We hope that you understand that, you know, a Ruffian is a Ruffian, and every Ruffian is here to sing us all, you know, me, Fuwawa, and me, Mococo, and Fuwamoco, together.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
But yeah, you know, something a little bit different than maybe open to now, or what you expect.
Throwing your expectations out of the water.
But we hope you'll check them out, Ruffians, over on MiiChip's website.
BAU BAU!
Even when you're cheering on FUWAMOCO.
Exactly.
Are they limited?
I'm not too sure.
I don't know.
It's best to go check them out if you're telling us.
Check out the website and there will be an answer.
BAU BAU!
I would say though, Shiori looks very cute, very smiley.
Biboo has a Kirby feeling to her too, you know.
FUWAMOCO I love it so much!
FUWAMOCO Very cute.
All together Advent!
BAU BAU!
And, well, I know that we mentioned it earlier, but this weekend is a big weekend, Ruffians!
Because, well, FUWAMOCO, we have a big performance over at Anime Boston!
For the first time ever in the USA, there's going to be a super karaoke party with hololive memes!
And it's happening in Boston!
Moco-chan how are you feeling?
Nervous.
How do I say that in Boston style?
Is that?
Is that sound more like Boston?
It's how they say nervous in Boston.
I'm wicked nervous.
I'm wicked nervous over here.
Does that make you better?
Drop the ice, drop the ice.
I'm wicked nervous.
I'm wicked excited.
You know, I think we're a bit of both.
But we're gonna do our best, you know, not to get too stiff or freeze up, you know.
Yeah, we're just gonna have fun and karaoke all together again!
You know, karaoke's just like that.
But for the Ruffians that might not be able to go all the way to Boston, you know, that makes sense sometimes.
We'll do our best!
We're gonna do our best and hopefully we'll have some photos to share with you!
I'm not sure about videos.
But, if we can, we win this song.
But also, you know, it's not just gonna be us and Bii-senpai there.
Also, FUWAMOCO English -Justice-!
They have Elizabeth, Gigi, Sissy, and Nala there too!
They're gonna be doing something different from us all.
They're gonna be doing their own panel.
And they're doing... Meet and Greet.
Moco-chan, are you jealous?
Well, we get to see so many Ruffians!
I am now a part of hololive English -Justice-!
I could replace Naoraboko-chan!
Naoraboko-chan!
Na
Yeah.
Okay, Moco-chan.
I was convinced.
Just put on the hat.
Put the hat on the cat.
Yes.
Except you're a demon dog, Moco-chan.
I'm tired of people saying I misunderstand, huh?
Huh?
But we hope, BAU BAUs, that you'll be there.
That you'll be able to cheer us on.
And maybe you can visit Justice as well.
We'll do our best to bring you the first hololive Mii Super Karaoke Party!
BAU BAU!
You thought it was later than one?
No, it's this weekend.
It's this weekend, yeah.
Get ready for it!
BAU BAU!
Well, in other news.
Something strange happened.
Something strange happened on Twitter.
Well, I feel like FUWAMOCO, we're the only hololive English members that don't make weird tweets.
And I think that says something.
This is true Ruffians.
We don't really tweet weird things, right?
Well, can we say it first?
You don't think this is true?
I don't know.
Fuwawa thinks our Twitter is normal.
I think our Twitter is normal.
We have to get weirder, Moco-chan.
Whatever that means.
We have to start tweeting every hour.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
We do teach at every hour!
BAU BAU Buttercup!
BAU BAU!
Wicked Fuel.
I can't think of any dimensions.
I can't think what my system would be!
It still sounds pretty normal, huh?
I don't know, we have to become a BAU BAU Bot or something.
Basically like that.
BAU BAU!
It was a BAU BAU BAU kind of thing that was tweeted by Kari-senpai!
She made kind of a strange tweet.
What did it mean?
All she said was just, I love orange woman.
So you know, I'm like, what about Fuwawa?
And I took that as a challenge to become orange.
And so, I became orange!
Orange, orange!
Orange Fuwawa!
Yeah!
And it's sort of funny because I feel like it seems like Ruffians seem to think that Fuwawa says orange is sort of funny.
Orange!
Is this true?
I'm orange!
Not blue anymore!
Orange!
Orange.
But look!
Somehow it kind of works, right Moco-chan?
I'm very happy being blue though.
I like normal stuff.
Yeah.
But I think it worked out and I was able to do it pretty quickly.
But, you know, it was getting kind of late and that's why, you know, probably Calli-senpai made the silly tweet and then I decided to
Trying to get her attention.
That's right, because it was late, you're blaming it on the time of night.
Yeah.
So you thought it would be funny?
Because it was late?
Yeah.
And then you know what?
What?
I was happy because I was like, yeah, I did it!
I'm orange now!
Yeah!
And then Moco-chan was like, what about Mococo?
And I said no.
It's not because I'm mean, FUWAMOCO!
It's because- Because it was late.
And I was tired.
Time I spent on this.
I'm Fuwawa!
Time I spent and now it's done.
It wasn't that much though.
But I did it in a kind of roundabout way.
But I did it!
So that's the important thing.
I think the most important thing is that you're normal.
I'm normal Moco-chan.
Not orange.
Can you give me more compliments?
You are normal.
A little fluffy.
Normal.
Like this.
Average.
Everyday.
Just start, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Well, speaking of everyday... One thing I love that doesn't happen everyday, but it happens every FUWAMOCO morning... Is the Doggie of the Day!
Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... This!
It's PETA!
PETA!
Look at PETA!
So fluffy!
Now this is a fluffy dog, huh?
Right, you know, look!
Look, PETA and I, we still have the same little fluff, fluff...
The Little Flips.
Yorai Hairstyles.
Kizuna.
It's Peanut.
Look at us.
Atsumi.
Look at all the flowing hair.
The longest.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
No, but it's delicious.
Delicious?
Deliciously cute!
Being kind eyes, yes.
Yeah.
But this makes Peanut a baby.
Right, baby Peanut?
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Peanut BAU BAU?
I feel like it's very... No.
BAU!
BAU BAU!
Very friendly, like an alarm.
A bit alarming.
A bit alarming!
You know, I guess you know Peanuts a big dog.
Very beautiful dog, but also a dog.
A bit alarming.
Yeah, that makes sense.
But you know, Peanuts, I think we can tell that Peanuts is super sweetie.
And is the definition of friendly.
So that means we have to give all the head pats and belly rubs.
All of them.
All of the belly rubs.
Some of the head pats.
The peanut.
And maybe some treats too!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next we have one!
Today I went on a walk segment!
Ruffians!
Where were you at walking, huh?
Let's take a look!
De-den!
Wait, what is this?
Oh, cute!
A wrestling match with your son!
Aww, too cute!
Wow, thank you for being a fan of us!
I didn't know taking us along a very special, extreme, violent moment.
Ah, in case you didn't know, Ruffians!
We didn't wrestle.
We did do wrestling!
Real wrestling!
Does this make us professional wrestlers?
I feel a little sad because I see that people have forgotten.
I have not forgotten how hard we worked that we trained in our 3D debut!
We fought to the death!
Real blood!
But you know, don't forget, Mococo won!
It's fine Moco-chan because I think there's a battle in order again.
One day we'll be back and let us wrestle.
Just you watch, okay Ruffians?
But you better not forget!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
We hope you enjoyed it!
Extreme violence!
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is...
BAU BAU!
Mama!
I've wondered for a while.
How impressive is your collection of Twitter bookmark folders?
I know one is for home decor ideas, and I've noticed you have art and clips at the ready for almost any situation.
Do you each have a few personal folders?
Well, I don't think it's probably as sophisticated as you think.
Um, we talked about a downloads folder, right?
Don't I ask?
A bit more organized in that way than that.
A bit more.
Yeah.
You know, we have lots and lots and lots of book breaks.
But I think the busiest one is the folder that Mane-chan uses for FUWAMOCO Morning.
That makes sense, because Mane-chan is probably more organized.
Yeah, but I did notice the Twitter's funny.
And if you start scrolling a bunch, it will show things out of chronological order.
That kind of makes it really difficult.
How is that not surprising?
I don't know, it makes things tricky though for Mane-chan, I think.
And it makes it hard to stay organized too!
And for our other folders as well!
Yeah, we really like to be able to see the Ruffians' special tweets in different folders so that we can go back and look at them!
We know ideas!
Oh, fanworks too!
Yeah.
But hopefully, you know, maybe there's a way that the bookmarks folder can get a little bit more organized in the future.
Who knows though, it might just go poop.
Yeah.
I think that's one of the reasonable ones.
Maybe.
But yeah, how's the download folder looking nowadays?
Even worse.
That's right.
What?
I can't remember.
Remember there's that one file that we're gonna look for but we didn't look for it.
Oh no, I made a note for that.
Oh, I already know where it is.
It's not in the downloads folder.
The one file not in the... I'm taking, loading, loading, loading.
Downloads folder is... 40, just, just over 44,000 files.
Wow, that's not bad.
I think it doubled in size than last time.
Yay!
Over!
It'll get organized in the future, right Moco-chan?
No.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
And thank you for always being a very important part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're always waiting for more Doggy of the Days, more questions!
We want to see your walk, so please send us your walks!
And if you have any Pero sightings, let us know what you've been dealing with with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you
Birthday girl.
Toy-senpai.
Bae-senpai.
Yeah, Boston buddy.
Hajime and Vivi!
A big ripple group.
Right?
It's gonna be very interesting.
I know this is funny.
I didn't know it would happen, huh?
Let's stay alive and be helpful.
Let's not drop things and break them, okay?
We can leave that to somebody else like Vivi.
I think Vivi's gonna do all the damage.
I have a feeling it's okay.
It's not gonna be us though.
No!
We have a cute boy too!
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the icons today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU Boston people!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's been a very fun week.
Thank you for joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning today too!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Patsumata!
BAU BAU!
Shiyoming Miro!
Keiki!
BAU BAU!
Syuko!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
As every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!